es una sentencia histórica el
expresidente Israel bolsonaro está
oficialmente inhabilitado por 8 años los
siete jueces del tribunal superior
electoral se pronunciaron este viernes
sobre su caso y cinco de ellos lo
reconocieron culpable de abuso de poder
el ponente votó a favor de descartar las
cuestiones preliminares y sobre el fondo
conceder parcialmente la solicitud de
condena del primer acusado Jair Mesías
bolsonaro por la práctica de abuso de
poder político y uso indebido de los
medios de comunicación en las elecciones
de 2022 declarándolo inelegible por 8
años
el expresidente fue condenado por haber
deslegitimado el sistema electoral
especialmente durante una reunión con
Embajadores en el Palacio presidencial
en la cual atacó al sistema devoto
electrónico a sólo tres meses de las
elecciones de 2022 también fue
reconocido culpable de uso debido de los
medios de comunicación ya que transmitió
dicho evento en la televisión pública el
expresidente denunció su condena y
anunció que apelará la decisión
Hoy es un día emblemático para mí como
el 6 de septiembre de 2018 cuando me
apuñalaron Hoy recibí una puñalada por
la espalda con esta decisión no es a
Yair Mesías bolsonaro a quien le dieron
esta puñalada sino a la democracia
bolso no podrá presentarse en las
próximas elecciones presidenciales
previstas para 2026 sin embargo el ex
jefe de estado de extrema derecha ya
avisó que podría apoyar a la eventual
candidatura de su esposa Michelle
bolsonaro para las presidenciales
enfrenta a otra decena de
investigaciones judiciales que podrían
ponerlo tras las rejas